With the release of 2021's Eternals, the Marvel
superhero known as Ajak will finally be coming
to the silver screen, as portrayed by
Salma Hayek. But who exactly is Ajak,
and why is the character so important to the
Eternals? This is Ajak's story explained.
Although they haven't always been at
the forefront of most fans' minds,
the Eternals cast a huge shadow over
the history of the Marvel universe.
Those mutations that make the X-Men so
uncanny? They're tied to the Eternals' origin.
Thanos? He's involved with them too,
in a roundabout way: The Eternals
once colonized a little place called Titan,
which became home to Thanos centuries later.
"I am… inevitable."
The Eternals are essentially the product of
experimentation, performed by an ancient,
omnipotent group of super-sized humanoids
called the Celestials. The Celestials
tinkered with humanity's genetic code,
creating two offshoot races: The grotesque
creatures known as the Deviants, and the immortal,
super-powered beings that make up the Eternals.
Despite looking like humans, the Eternals
are very nearly divine in their abilities:
They can control the aging process,
cast illusions, fly, read minds,
and transform matter. Essentially, they are
gods, and have often ended up becoming the
source of many of humanity's legends, religions,
and fables. For example, the Eternal Sersi was
immortalized as Circe in Homer's Odyssey, while
Ikaris' life inspired the ancient tale of Icarus.
Like his fellow Eternals, Ajak has a rich
backstory of his own. However, to fully understand
who he is, it's important to understand what he
can do. Ajak is equipped with superhuman strength,
for one. He can also fly at speed, teleport,
and do almost everything that falls under the
general category of "energy manipulation." When
it comes time to throw down against the bad guys,
he's capable of projecting beams of heat and
concussive energy from his eyes and hands.
He is also a brilliant archaeologist — perhaps
helped by the fact that he was around for much
of the history he digs up. In some of the latest
Eternals stories, Ajak has also been shown to
have the power to change gender, although it's
uncertain how much of this constitutes a retcon.
Uniquely, Ajak possesses an uncanny
ability to communicate with the Celestials.
This is pretty much his signature ability
when it comes to protecting humanity,
as few other Eternals are able to do it.
And given that the Celestials have a habit
of showing up every now and again to see
if they feel like destroying the Earth,
it's fair to say that Ajak's powers
are pretty vital to the team.
Ajak was born in the Eternal city of Polaria,
located in the Ural Mountains, to parents named
Rakar and Amaa. His branch of the species is
sometimes referred to as the Polar Eternals.
Not much is known about Ajak prior to
the Celestials' intervention in his life,
but it is known that Ajak and his brother Arex
were active in ancient Greece around 1200 BC,
where the former was either mistaken for
the mythical hero of the Trojan War, Ajax.
Unfortunately, there's very little information
about what happened to Arex after the brothers'
time in Greece came to an end. He pops
up only very rarely in the Marvel canon,
and the jury is out as to whether
or not he's even still alive.
After Greece, Ajak wandered the Earth,
making his way to places such as Babylon,
where he took on the Deviant leader, Warlord Kro.
After that, he spent some time in the Americas,
where he was worshiped as a god. The Aztecs paid
tribute to him as Quetzalcoatl, one of the
wisest and most powerful of their deities.
In time, the Incas also came to worship
Ajak as Tecumotzin, the Lord of Flight,
and Ajak wasn't shy about using his supreme
power to advance the civilizations he favored.
By 1000 AD, Ajak was an accomplished warrior,
cosmic genius, and influential figure in the
progress of humanity. While that would be enough
for most superheroes to hang their hats on,
however, Ajak's greatest feats yet would
come with the return of the Celestials.
Unable to escape his own past, Ajak crossed
paths with both the Celestials and the Deviants
once again, when the former returned to
Earth on a fact-finding mission. This
is because Earth wasn't the only planet
the Celestials decided to experiment on:
The home worlds of races such as the Skrulls and
the Kree got the same treatment, for example.
To help judge whether or not they
had been a success, the Celestials
subjected each race to four tests, or
"hosts," to deem them worthy of life.
During the Third Host, Ajak was living in Peru.
He acted as a liaison between the Celestials
and humanity, as well as a go-between for the
Celestials and the gods humanity had given rise
to, such as Zeus of the Greek pantheon. Luckily,
humanity passed the test with flying colors,
and Ajak decided to put his atoms into
storage until the Celestials returned.
Eventually, the Fourth Host of
Celestials returned to Earth to
see how their experiments were faring — kicking
off Ajak's story in the modern Marvel universe.
Ajak is awoken by Ikaris in
1976's Eternals #2. Soon after,
the Celestials once again come to South
America, and settle on an Incan plateau
that Ajak has set up for them. And
once again, he acts as their liaison.
This time, however, their presence sparks
intervention from the likes of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
as well as Odin and the forces of Asgard.
"Because that's -"
"Because that's what heroes do."
Despite the combined efforts of all three
factions, Earth ends up losing the fight
against the Celestials. However, the battle helps
the Celestials realize that humanity is worthy,
and therefore, they agree to
let the Earth off the hook.
Most of the important players have their
memories erased of the whole incident,
and the Eternals realize they needn't worry
about the Celestials' interventions anymore.
So it's good news all around, but it
also means that Ajak is out of a job.
During the Fourth Host event, Ajak befriends
a human archaeologist named Dr. Daniel Damian.
After Ikaris brings the brilliant
doctor along to awaken Ajak,
the two become thick as thieves — Damien even
watches the Fourth Host event take place from
within the Celestials' impenetrable dome.
However, he is more interested in preserving
the history of the Incas than he is in
making sure humanity passes its test.
Damian begins with all the makings of
a classic superhero ally… but grief
does horrible things to people. His daughter,
Margo, flees the Celestials' city with Ikaris,
while Damian agrees to stay behind to protect
history. Ikaris and Margo are separated,
and she is later turned into a Deviant
and killed in an attempt to get to Ikaris.
In the wake of this tragedy, Damian seeks revenge
on Celestials, Deviants, Eternals — the lot of
them. Part of his plan includes an elaborate
trick against the Eternals and Deviants:
specifically, he turns Ajak into a
literal monster. Needless to say,
Damian's relationship with the Eternals sours, and
his friendship with Ajak dies a miserable death.
Damian's plan involves planting false prophecies
about the twin offspring of Eternals and Deviants
being the ones to eventually conquer both races.
He then uses advanced Celestial technology to
transform Ajak into a monster whose sole purpose
seems to be systematically hunting down and
killing twin siblings on Earth. Thus mutated,
Ajak assists in the kidnapping of twins Donald
and Deborah Ritter, the offspring of the Eternal
Thena and the Deviant Kro. Fortunately, the
doctor's plan to kill the twins in front of their
parents fails when Ikaris gets wise to the whole
situation and, disgusted with his own actions,
Ajak disintegrates both himself and Damian.
Luckily, this all happens in the world of comic
books, where death is merely a distraction.
Ajak is eventually resurrected in the chambers
of the Eternal city of Olympia by an Eternal
named Sprite. Sprite is later revealed to be
deceiving Ajak and the other Eternals into
helping him use the power of the fabled
Dreaming Celestial to overwrite reality.
Sprite's plot is thwarted, but it leads to an
enduring rivalry between Ajak and another Eternal;
one that would result in his
second death and resurrection.
When the Dreaming Celestial is awoken, it
chooses the Eternal Makkari as its spokesperson.
Obviously, Ajak's experience
in this field is extensive,
so he understandably feels a little slighted
by this choice, and soon grows to hate Makkari.
He even hatches a plan to kill him — but
while Makkari does die, it doesn't stick.
Now at loose ends, Ajak decides to travel the
world and learn as much as he can about the
Celestials. He lives in San Francisco for
a time, and even becomes a gardener. This
journey eventually leads Ajak to join Hercules
in a battle with the Skrull Gods, in which he
squares off with a divine Skrull named Kly'bn.
It's during this fight that Ajak dies again.
Again, this being the Marvel universe, Ajak's
death doesn't last. He returns to Earth and
travels to Olympia, where he lives among his
fellow Eternals. However, all this changes the
day dead Celestials rain from the sky, signaling
the arrival of the Dark Celestials on Earth.
That's when the Eternals learn a terrible
secret about themselves and their existence;
one that leads all of them to either
turn on each other or kill themselves.
Of course, once again, they've
all been revived. Ajak stars,
as a woman, alongside Makkari in the
2021 Eternals: Celestia one-shot.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel Comics characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.